hey 42 here
if you happen to be living in london in
1821 you would have witnessed an
unseasonably late flurry of snow on the
27th of may considering it was almost
summer such weather was pretty miserable
now being british i could talk about the
weather all day even the weather from
two centuries ago but that's not what's
going on here what i'm actually doing is
employing a little known literary
technique known as pathetic fallacy not
to be confused with prophetic phallus
which is something you call your enemy
when you've run out of insults
pathetic fallacy is when we give human
feelings in this case being miserable to
something non-human in this case the
weather by doing that we can use the
atmosphere above london to reflect the
bleak feelings of the people below
but why you may ask were the poor
citizens of london feeling so down
well after 20 years of conflict in
continental europe including the
napoleonic wars and the battle of
waterloo the british economy was as
depressed as the weather for the
privileged classes of early 19th century
england there was little to look forward
to apart from raising a few glasses of
brandy at the coronation of king george
iv which was set to take place in july
1821 but before anyone could get two
down in the dumps an exciting character
appeared in their midst
the exotic ruler of a far-off land who
was apparently in town to celebrate the
crowning of the new king
this man general gregor mcgregor
introduced himself as the kazeek or
prince of poise a bountiful land in
central america
haven't heard of it
don't worry neither had anyone else
but according to the kazeek it was a
veritable paradise the rivers that
meandered their way to the ocean there
were littered with huge deposits of gold
and silver
the land was fertile and crops like
maize could be harvested three times a
year instead of the usual twice and both
fish and game were so plentiful that
hunting for a day would deliver a week's
supply of food on top of natural beauty
and abundance poise was also blessed
with the beginnings of a thriving
civilization which included a democratic
government a fully functional civil
service and its own national bank and
military
the capital saint joseph was a thriving
town with wide boulevards mansions and
its own opera house it was the land of
milk and honey and would you believe it
the prince and his government were
looking for investors in what was said
to be the opportunity of a lifetime
if all this sounds a bit too good to be
true then congratulations you probably
weren't born yesterday but the early
19th century was a more innocent era
than our own and hundreds of investors
and wannabe settlers bet their fortunes
and futures on mcgregor's grand vision
of a utopia halfway around the world
of course priest was like so much that
came out of mcgregor's mouth
but by the time anyone realized the
truth the man from the mosquito coast
had pulled off one of the ballsiest cons
in history one that cost numerous people
their lives and even contributed to the
collapse of the stock market but let's
not get too far ahead of ourselves first
we need to rewind a bit to the start of
this story
because the only way to understand how a
man sold off an imaginary country
is to understand the man himself
the prince of peace
mr gregor mcgregor
he was born on christmas eve 1786 and
came from a strong scottish lineage of
adventurous and military men his father
was a sea captain with the east india
company his grandfather a distinguished
soldier in the british army and his
great great uncle was the almost
mythical scottish rebel and outlaw rob
roy
so it's no surprise that gregor had a
taste for a fight and joined the british
army at 16. his family bought him an
office's commission which meant he
earned her rank without needing anything
as trivial as leadership skills hard
work or merit
but despite the shortcuts mcgregor did
show some natural ability and soon found
himself promoted to lieutenant of the
57th regiment of foot within the first
year of training a position that
normally would have taken three years to
achieve he'd reached the first
significant rung in what would be an
epic climb up the military and social
ladders when he was just 19 he married
maria beau water the daughter of an
admiral and a wealthy well-connected
woman
with his newfound access to serious cash
gregor bought himself another promotion
this time to the rank of captain
the move cost him 900 pounds that's
about 80 000 pounds in today's money but
it allowed him to skip seven years of
frankly inconvenient work and grind
usually required for that sort of
promotion and you thought pay to win was
a modern invention
after a year in portugal supporting the
duke of wellington in the peninsula war
mcgregor left the army and moved to
edinburgh where he tried to pass himself
off to scottish high society as a
colonel and a man of great importance
his old regiments to 57 foot had
distinguished themselves at the battle
of albora earning the nickname die hards
and gregor was only too happy to take
his share of the glory despite the small
detail that that battle had taken place
a year after his discharge from the army
in the end edinburgh didn't embrace him
and he and his wife moved back to london
where he upped the stakes even further
rebranding himself sir gregor mcgregor
clan chief of the mcgregors
had the ruse worked we might today know
gregor's face from shortbread biscuits
tins everywhere but it wasn't to be
because shortly after returning to
london gregor's wife died and so did his
primary source of income unable to fund
the lavish london lifestyle befitting
his made-up rank gregor decided to
reinvent himself yet again
in the early part of the 19th century a
war of independence was being waged
against the spanish in venezuela
one of the leaders of this rebellion
general francisco de miranda had made
quite a splash when he visited london
and gregor decided to seek his fortune
in miranda's army
after arriving in venezuela he offered
his services directly to miranda
introducing himself as sir gregor
mcgregor of the 57th foot a military man
of such distinction was of course
welcomed with open arms and gregor was
immediately made a colonel with a
cavalry battalion at his command he had
mixed results in a series of early
campaigns but he saw some
extracurricular action too
marrying his second wife joseph in june
1812.
she was a cousin of the legendary
revolutionary leader simon bolova the
man for whom bolivia is named
which probably had something to do with
mcgregor's promotion to brigadier
general in the very same month he may
not have been all he claimed to be but
mcgregor knew how to fake it until he
made it and soon enough he began to show
something of a flair for leadership
displaying courage and generally
distinguishing himself on the
battlefield he ended the revolutionary
war as general of division in the army
of venezuela and its neighbour new
granada during this time mcgregor
achieved his greatest military success
leading 1200 men in a 34-day retreat
across venezuela
outsmarting and outmaneuvering two
royalist armies at every turn according
to modern scholars it was a display of
genuine military skill and it made
mcgregor a legend earning him fame and
prestige the following years saw
mcgregor seek further fortune and glory
in florida then under the control of the
spanish
but sadly the fortune turned out to be
mixed and the glory limited
by 1820 after a series of failed
offensives mcgregor had fallen out with
his superiors and found himself in need
of a new image for the umpteenth time
luckily the perfect opportunity to
create exactly that was waiting right
around the corner literally it came when
mcgregor and a group of his supporters
landed on the mosquito coast a territory
stretching across modern-day honduras
and nicaragua in exchange for some rum
and jewelry the local ruler king george
frederick augustus sold mcgregor 8
million acres of useless inhospitable
land
but if you've learned anything about
mcgregor by now it's that he never let
facts get in the way of a good story
where others saw vast reaches of jungle
and in fertile turf mcgregor saw dollar
signs
he set sail for england at once and by
the time he arrived in london he
transformed himself into the so-called
prince of poise all that was needed for
this kingdom to become a reality was
some money in the royal coffers and a
bunch of gullible suckers to become his
loyal subjects
when gregor landed in britain in 1821
tales of his military successes in
central america were already well known
and those stories gave him a platform of
credibility from which he launched a
spectacular fraud
he claimed to rule over a utopian land
called poise
where vast riches awaited anyone brave
enough to seek them out with their
extravagant displays of apparent royal
wealth and fantastical stories of
paradise mcgregor and his wife were the
favorites of socialites everywhere the
sales campaign that mcgregor fronted for
his scheme is quite possibly one of the
largest and most complex of any scam in
history he opened poe's consulates
across england
invented an entire military complete
with its own uniform and ranks
designed a flag you've got to have a
flag
dreamed up a complex banking system and
came up with his own aristocratic titles
mcgregor gave interviews in national
newspapers and even hired singers to
roam the streets of london edinburgh and
glasgow belting out poyasian ballads
to top it all off he wrote a compelling
guidebook to his fictional country under
the pseudonym captain thomas strangeways
complete with lavish illustrations
it was all so convincing that a
prominent london bank eagerly underwrote
mcgregor's fraudulent poison bonds
without batting an eyelid
many brits invested their entire life
savings buying up poised land or
purchasing poise government bonds
worthless shares in an economy that
didn't even exist
there were plenty of willing settlers
too mostly scots who trusted their
fellow countrymen unquestioningly
and the more that signed up the more
credible the whole scheme seemed in the
end there were enough settlers to fill
seven ships
in those days the sheer amount of time
it took to travel to far-off regions
like central america made it impossible
to verify claims like those mcgregor
made plus most of the stories that
reached britain at the time were of
revolutions and changing governments in
exotic lands
so the possibility of there being an
unknown nation on an uncharted part of
the world map
seemed totally plausible
with that all counting in his favor
mcgregor raised 200 000 pounds
from people in all walks of life
from professionals to ordinary families
that's more than 23 million pounds in
today's money
now scamming people out of their
hard-earned cash for your own benefit is
one thing
but it takes a special kind of bastard
to let women and children board ships to
a far-off land that doesn't actually
exist purely to make a few quid yeah but
that's exactly what happened the
honduras packet set sail from london on
the 10th of september 1822
carrying the first 70 poise pioneers
a few months later a further 200 would
escape dreary lives in scotland aboard
the kennersley castle many of the
passengers had even swapped the last of
their boring old british pounds for the
much sexier poised dollar notes
which were of course meaningless pieces
of paper printed in edinburgh when the
honduras packet arrived at its
destination in november 1822 she
announced her arrival in port and waited
to be met by local officials but of
course
no one came
assuming they'd simply been dropped off
in the wrong place the passengers
disembarked anyway most wearing their
finest dress to mark this momentous
occasion they set up camp expecting to
be found by the piezon authorities
within days if not hours
but when the next 200 settlers arrived
their excitement was quickly crushed
when they found nothing but a group of
would-be colonists
trying to survive in a makeshift camp
it's fair to say that life in the camp
was grim
torrential rains brought disease and the
colonists descended into hopelessness
discontent violence
and even suicide
the mexican eagle a ship from british
honduras carrying an envoy to the
mosquito king came across the settlers
many of whom were sick dying or dead
those who could be saved were rescued by
the mexican eagle in free return trips
to honduras
the remaining five ships that were due
to bring more immigrants to poise were
thankfully intercepted by the royal navy
or avoided landing after spotting the
remains of the camp
in honduras most of the remaining
pioneers would perish when disease
ripped through their number a small
contingent would return to london
arriving in october 1823
predictably though mcgregor had already
left town for paris
where almost unbelievably he repeated
the entire deception
this time raising 300 000 pounds
but the authorities got suspicious when
a number of french citizens applied for
passports to travel to a country that
didn't exist
and mcgregor was eventually arrested
after some time on the run but the
scotsman was a survivor and in 1826 he
managed to get himself acquitted quickly
returning to london with his family
by now the payee's controversy had died
down and mcgregor continued selling land
chairs in central america
though on a much smaller scale than
before
eventually he was put out of business
when the mosquito king himself started
to sell legitimate land claims for the
mosquito coast after claiming mcgregor
had no legal right to the land
getting on in years and running out of
cash mcgregor finally returned to
venezuela in 1838 where he was
celebrated as a hero of the liberation
movement in venezuela he saw out his
final years living off a military
pension
dying in 1845 with a full military
burial
he never faced punishment for any of the
players fraud or for the lives lost by
the player settlers who'd bought into
his sick fantasies some historians
suspect mcgregor himself was probably
guilty of believing the myth he'd spun
and that he genuinely hoped to build
himself a kingdom on the mosquito coast
regardless of whether or not that may be
true his recklessness and greed
ultimately cost the lives and
livelihoods of thousands of innocent
people the effects were felt well beyond
those who invested too speculation in
latin america in general and employees
in particular
directly led to the stock market crash
of 1825
also known as the panic
considered to be the first modern
financial crisis
the panic saw 12 banks go under and
almost brought about the ruin of the
bank of england
all for a country that didn't exist
gregor mcgregor has been dead for more
than 170 years but his legacy lives on
to this day as you've probably noticed
unscrupulous individuals are attempting
to part you from your money pretty much
constantly
thankfully most of them are a hell of a
lot less convincing
than our man mcgregor
thanks for watching